MALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, I want to bring up
a good friend of mine.
He's going to perform for you
guys and just amaze you like
he amazes me.
Ladies and gentlemen, Darien.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "COMPOSURE"]
DARIEN: How you all doing?
How you all doing?
Let's not get it twisted.
He's talking $30,000.
Talking about $10 to buy
a CD but I got $30,000.
Boy, you better [INAUDIBLE].
Let's start this up, though.
Listen.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "COMPOSURE"]
DARIEN: We going to
get to know each
other tonight, y'all.
We going to get the vibe,
get the groove.
Short time, but we are going
to get to know each other.
You're going to know me as not
the dude with the $30,000, but
the dude who was trying to bring
y'all a little bit of
independent soul music.
You know what I'm saying?
So we're going to do it.
Just a little something
like that.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "COMPOSURE"]
DARIEN: Thank you.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you, y'all.